You're back live.
Hi.
and I'll talk about what we're going to
do today.
One second.
This is going to be um
So, we're basically going to try to get
everything done for release
except pressing the launch button.
Pretty much that.
So, what do we have to do to get there?
Well, unfortunately, uh the jobs that we
had last night died because power
outage, which is always fun. Uh we did
get some data though before they died.
In particular, the latest stuff on
neural MMO looks very, very good.
all these different sweeps that I did.
And uh this one on Neural MMO.
Now, you never really want to bet too
much on these upticks at the end because
um
there's like sampling bias. But if we
even if we look sort of here at this
sort of portion of the curve, I think
it's very likely we get something above
seven in a reasonable amount of time.
And uh I don't know, we might end up
actually seeing something way way better
if we run this for even longer. So I've
started up this new one here. It's tiny.
Also a fair bit of variance from run to
run. So it's always not like it's not
always super easy to say. This is
literally the same run that I've started
and just it's bought on a little
quicker. Um but regardless, we'll see
what this does. There's also I've seen
some instability where some of these
runs uh kind of crash after a bit. So
like the reward crashes, but we'll see.
You know, we'll monitor this throughout
the day and we'll hope that the uh there
are no more power interruptions.
I can guarantee there will be no more
power interruptions
in a few days because uh we're going to
have the UPS installed. It's a backup
generator. It's just that right now it
doesn't switch over fast enough. So
that'll all be taken care of. Cool. Um,
let's actually just get the master list
real quick of like
things we need to do. Finally launch
this. Done with this launch. Way way way
too long. Want to move on and work on
other things around RL with Puffer.
baselines
for all environments
run
port all baselines
to website.
I am fine here. Uh either
downscale
or simplify annoying
policies
cuz I don't want to spend all day just
writing C networks.
Square
available.
I think the other main things we got to
double check. Whoops.
maybe around some of
SPI
The new M's don't have articles,
individual articles yet, but that will
be resolved.
Other things I promised for release.
I mean, there's always going to be like
testing
pie
going to be a pain.
More than anything else, I just want
this to not be broken on release, right?
I don't want to not have a whole bunch
of support issues where we have like
basic installation stuff or whatever.
I think that's kind of it.
What's going on with this thing? Oh,
okay.
Cool. Yeah, that does then. Um, that
already 1.5 bill. Yeah, that's crazy.
Literally, while I've been talking, I
launched this right before I started
stream. This is already done. 1.5
billion steps in neural MMO. For
context, that's uh about 30 years worth
of games.
Billion seconds is 30 some odd years.
And uh the game rate is one step per 0.6
seconds.
I'm pretty sure I've already done this
for pong and breakout as well.
We'll do this
here.
There is frame skip here, but we're
smoothing frames.
I believe we did the new enduro policy
as well.
So, we can get I'm sure we can get
reasonable policies for most of these
things.
You can just immediately see the
difference, right?
with the recurrent policy. Hey.
Well, hang on. It's
there is a one hot requirement, right?
Oh, that's funny.
You don't need coms.
Isn't that funny?
Look at that.
You need you need the one hot encoder,
but you actually don't need coms.
3 million steps a second. 3.5. That's
lovely.
It does have like a decent chunk more
params, but like do we care? Faster.
I think what we're going to do,
let's do a Billy.
Yes, rewards are automatically being
clipped to negative one to one in the uh
Puffarel file. And the reason for that,
we did that after we spent forever
trying to figure out why breakout
wouldn't work. And it ended up being a
wrapper difference. And I decided screw
it. we're going to clip all the rewards
and then you can tune around it. Um, and
if your env has bigger reward
magnitudes, you should probably fix
that.
So, what I would suggest instead is you
change the reward magnitudes of the
other ones to probably be smaller. You
are going to have to tune because like
the defaults, the defaults kind of
assume that you're roughly in the oneish
reward range. Like I tend to use things
between maybe 0.1 at the very lowest and
uh one at the highest or negative one to
one but like 0.1 is the smallest uh
distinguisher from zero.
Also yo Spencer it turns out you don't
need coms for snake you just need the uh
the one hot encoder.
So I think we actually are going to be
able to make a lot of the network
architectures way faster if we do this.
Um, hell, I might Yeah, I have all sorts
of things I can do with this now. It's
kind of funny.
It turns out you don't need coms when
you have this much data.
Yeah. So, it's you do need the uh you
need the one hot encoding.
And actually, I'm going to do this for
our default nets for now. Even though I
the com is like technically kind of
smarter. Uh the reason I'm going to do
this for default nets is that they run
faster. So, I can actually run these on
the web way easier
global. Well, it's not necessarily that
coms are bad. It's just um
at least the way we have them now,
they're kind of slow, you know?
Like coms are not a bad building block
for what like we we should probably do
like some perf engineering at some
point. I don't know. There's so many
things I can potentially work on with
this stuff.
We need to like just knock down uh a
couple contracts or whatever so we can
get back to like really hammering the
fundamentals.
Uh, today will be a long is going to be
like long work day for me and I'm going
to attempt to get basically everything
all the remaining crap done for release.
So, we're basically ready to just do it.
whether I actually launch tomorrow or
whether we decide that we uh want to get
like a trailer cut together or stuff.
We'll see about that. But yeah.
No, it's from I see I've seen people do
this. Actually, I have a client that's
done this. Um people will put like point
like negative.
Z5 or like 0001
and like they'll wonder why the thing
isn't getting picked up. Like that's
basically going to get ignored unless
you have unless you have some other
hyperparameter that's effectively
scaling that thing up massively. Like
that ain't gonna do anything.
There's no actual clipping happening
like that's going to one or anything.
It's just negative one to one as the
only clip.
That helps.
the following content is provided. Oh
yeah, I started doing this uh solid
state chemistry stuff just in the
evening or whenever I'm doing things.
I'm just like starting to go through
diff different hard science stuff trying
to figure out um just like I don't know
enough to find all our apps. I DM' well.
Hello, Landor.
Welcome.
Um,
this guy will probably just reply today
because he's like terminally online.
He does cool stuff though. Uh, yeah.
Slander, have you seen Neural MMO 3.0?
So, we've got this thing here. This is
the new version of the environment.
It's actually human playable. So, if I
hit control here, I can like take over
and play for this guy. There's armor,
equipment, weapons, a market, and this
actually is like runs a thousand times
faster than my thesis. So, I actually
like after my thesis, I went back and I
did a crazy version of this.
Um, and we actually have this thing
training for like huge amounts of time
now. We have a run going right now on
six GPUs. That is I just started this.
This is already 5 billion steps in. I'm
trying to do a one trillion observation
run on this.
You're going to see some very cool
things around this quite soon.
We're also always looking for
contributors if you want to get involved
in building stuff like this. It is uh
well, I won't say it's not hard, but
I've made it a heck of a lot easier than
it used to be. And uh we actually have
lots of new people now all the time that
are getting involved with this type of
stuff that do not have prior RL
experience.
Plan for today is to fix the release box
in. So if you have stuff that you want
to get into the release on your
environment, get it in now,
right now.
How's it possible to get involved?
Very simple.
All this is on puffer.ai.
Start the repo on your way in. Helps me
out. And then I don't know why our
banner is broken, but if you just click
this discord.gg/puffer,
we've got like a thousand some odd
people in here. This is where we manage
all the dev. Um, pretty much new people.
If you're trying to get into RL, uh, I
suggest you start just by following our
new environment tutorial. It's in the 3
docs, which are beta, but they're coming
out and you can get them anyways early.
You build like a really simple
environment just to understand what is
happening. Uh, and then you build up to
like more complex and interesting stuff.
Uh, generally ways you can get involved.
New contributors should build
environments to see the endto-end loop
of like how do I get RL working on a new
problem. Then after that as you get more
uh advanced you can work on harder
environments that actually help us test
new areas of the science. You can get
involved with optimizing and working on
the algorithms and the science side in
puffer or the infrastructure which is
how we make everything run super fast.
I have prior RL experience. Well, then
you're actually ahead of a lot of the
people in here. So, the thing that I
think most people that come in from the
science side struggle with is the amount
of low-level dev we do. Um,
but like the low-level stuff, we do it
in a way that's very, very simple and
very, very powerful.
I have a summer to waste. Well, it's uh
I don't think you'll quite call it
wasting because if you see what we've
done in Puffer in just the last year,
the field is totally different. Um I
don't know how like if you've seen any
of the new stuff, but we literally have
reinforcement learning working out of
the box at millions of steps per second,
literally a thousand times faster than
anything else in the field. Uh we have
like 20 environments there. Many of them
are more complex and interesting than
all the things being used in academia.
We have new algorithms. We have new
infrastructure. It's all simpler than
what's out there as well. Like yeah,
there's some really cool stuff happening
in RL right now. I graduated a year ago,
so I'm done with PhD and uh now I'm
trying to fix the field and do so
outside of the confines of academia.
It's all open source as well.
Well, if you're interested in RL, this
is the
doing a masters in AI. I'm looking for
something in RL field for next year's
thesis. There's a lot of cool stuff you
can do now. Do I have the schooling
environment
here?
I don't think I have a trained model on
this, but I can run this space. Like I
built this thing in four days with
latest puffer. Are you going to be able
to even
here? Let me maybe
I'll train it for you so you can
actually see a little bit of what it
does. Um so this is now going to train
in at 2 minutes at a million and a half
steps per second. This is now keep in
mind this is a new environment that only
took me about 4 days to build with um
the way that we do stuff in latest
puffer lib.
If you take like SP3 speeds for a
network this size, it would be uh
literally like you'd look at maybe 5,000
steps per second. So this is
what's that 300x faster training and way
faster than that simulation.
And you'll see what this environment is
in just a second.
We have lots of stuff like this as well.
Yeah, I'm basically cleaning up for our
next uh our next release. Oh, yeah. This
is not even going to be the best policy
cuz I I ran a hyper pram sweep. Uh that
should get us better stuff. But uh
hopefully this this will at least show
you something cool.
Oh, and I do also I stream all the
development of puffer. So, I stream like
40 60 hours a week. Um, pretty much all
the dev,
That'll be done in a minute. I mean I
174 million steps is like and normally
if you look most academic RL papers the
x-axis is like a 100 million steps or
even 10 million steps and they run it
overnight. So kind of gives you an idea.
Heck I mean there are Atari 100k I think
the Atari 100k
uh experiments where they will take two
hours to run 100k frames. It's kind of
ridiculous.
I mean there are a few reasons I stream,
right? One is actually to get people
interested in contributing to stuff like
this, but also it's that if people have
questions on all these different things,
I can like I can help and provide
support live for stuff.
Yeah. Well, I think the training was a
bit unstable because it crashed right at
the end, but uh I don't know. Maybe
they'll still do something.
Can we see these? I mean, we can still
see them. They're just not very smart.
So yeah, these are all agents
individually controlled.
Probably see him fight in a second.
Yeah, there you go. You can see one of
the lasers.
Yeah, like the little laser beams that
go off occasionally. environment just
reset.
Yeah, we can build stuff like this now
and actually RL it. It's pretty cool.
It'll be way more interesting when I
have a policy for it, but
that's just a quick preview.
I mean, like a sim like that would kind
of be that's like the complexity of my
PhD thesis pretty much in terms of like
what the sim actually does. And instead
of taking five years, it took four days.
So that's how much like I basically what
I did is I took everything I learned in
my PhD thesis and then over the last
year um I've made I've just made the
process of doing of making complex
environments and training on them. I've
done like everything's a thousandx
better.
So this is my goal, right? This is my
goal is to fix the field to make
reinforcement learning uh like a stable
mature area of AI that like you know
language modeling didn't used to work
like LLMs they didn't used to work. I
worked on them in like 2017 2018 I think
2017 and like you could like see the
loss curve go down but the output was
pretty garbage and you could like barely
use them for stuff like sentiment
analysis. Uh, and then eventually, you
know, they kind of just started working
with all the new architecture changes,
with new data, with more scale. I'm
trying to do the same thing for RL.
Like, it's, if you think of RL as being
where that was back then, I'm trying to
do the same thing. Like, get it to this
point where it just freaking takes off.
All right, back to back to work on this.
So,
some reason this doesn't look like it is
working
cuz we have a better policy than this,
right?
Yeah. This is not the policy or the
quality of the policy.
have a nice day. See you.
See you around.
find a simpler find like a one or max
two-word name
tragedy would work because it's a
tragedy of the commons problem. Um, pool
would work if you just want pool of res
like, you know, pick something simpler,
you know,
it's not coupe cuz it's uh there are a
lot of cooperative problems that don't
have that that uh you're specifically
study studying like a tragedy of the
commons problem
or a pool re like our shared resource
pool problem like Pick something like
that.
You don't have to necessarily change
this stuff in the C. Like just make sure
the
You just have to change the file names I
think so that like
um it that it gets picked up in the
config, right? Like the thing I care
about is that the config is you run it
with like common pool or shared pool or
whatever. People need to know what the
thing is based on the uh the end name,
file name, folder name should be it.
There might be uh a couple like the
includes or whatever,
but that should be it.
Yeah. This is what snake is supposed to
look like. Yeah.
policy gradient should get diminishing
returns.
more correlated. It's dependent on the
environment complexity. Simple
environments get less out of larger
batch sizes because essentially you've
um
you can think of it as like information
gain or whatever like the amount of
additional information you get uh just
goes to zero. Eventually you get
diminishing returns because like you
already know everything from a certain
batch about how to update the policy
locally. But the thing is in a more
complex environment uh there's a lot
more noise. So you actually you need a
lot lot larger batches. And neural MMO
for instance right now neural MMO is
training with batch size 3 million and
it's very effective.
The neural MMO is just that hard.
Batch size 3 million and mini batch size
180,000.
I really wish the stupid power would not
take out my experiments. Um cuz I keep
getting like 80 billion steps in and
it's like it's like it's almost soda.
It's almost soda and then it crashes. So
I fixed all the memory leaks and things.
It's literally now just like power
outages screwing with me and we'll have
soda on neural MMO
prior to replay. How much did it help?
Depends on the environment. Can be
substantial. Sometimes is, sometimes
isn't. Uh advantage filtering overall is
quite substantial.
Storm issues where you live. Yeah, all
sorts of lightning.
For some reason, it never run. It never
rains on the day I actually go to run,
which annoys me because
I pretty much want it to only rain when
I go run.
The hell's wrong with this thing? Come
on.
I got to go for breakfast in a minute,
but I will be back for the whole day
afterwards working on this stuff.
We're going to get this whole thing
solved today.
You have anything that trains on this
thing yet? Like uh you know, I said like
you could try like smaller instances,
all sorts of things. Do you have
anything that you're happy with the
training of?
I I will include the environment in 3
regardless, but it would be cool to have
like a something that actually does, you
know, a training. And if you're
interested in this type of work in
general, like there's so much we can do
on uh multi- aent in general now with
the way it is that we build new MS.
I mean, honestly, the bottleneck is not
it's going to be like
it's just going to be environment dev
competence. like however many people we
have that are competent at very quickly
building small C environments without
screwing anything major up. Um that's
going to be like the main the main thing
because like I think that any individual
problem I want to study I can probably
have something done in 3 to four hours
now tops
but there are like quite a few of these
problems and then there's you know
follow-up research on them and lots of
right. I think I'm going to break for uh
for breakfast and we'll figure this
specific bug out when I'm back. Uh
thanks folks.
If you want to get involved, puffer.ai,
join the Discord, start the repo, help
me out, all that. Thank you, Box. and
I'll merge that after breakfast.